welcome back here to good day las vegas
metro sheriff joe lombardo joining us
again for the morning cup of joe's
segment good to see you sir
good morning john so april is sexual
assault awareness month and the rape
crisis center here in the valleys noted
an
increase in reports over the past few
weeks what can people do to avoid
becoming a victim
one is to be aware of your situations
and
make sure you do call us if you are
victimized or you feel you've been
victimized
and the most commonality associated with
this crime is
over consumption of alcohol and or drugs
um
com you know what the opening up of the
the economy and nightclubs starting to
see an increase in people
and everything that goes along with with
lifestyle and the nightlife
is conducive to people looking for
victims
i think the important piece for for
people in the community
is to be aware of their surroundings and
make sure you do everything
in a group if at all possible sheriff
murders in metro's jurisdiction also up
this year compared to the same time
last year any idea what's behind this
increase
yeah there's been a 52 percent increase
so what does 52 percent mean
if you put if you quantify it's 31
versus 19 year-to-date
and the most common factor associated
with those 31 is domestic violence and
and i've opined on this before i believe
it's to be
closely associated with covet and
unemployment
and and rent and mortgage payments and
everything else that goes along with
life
domestic violence is a big key in that
and that's been the
majority of the numbers associated with
murders so the bright light in that is
we've had a 97 percent
solvability of all those murders which
has a direct influence on subject
behavior
suspect behavior preventing them from
continuing the act into the future
sheriff another figure that's going up
is deadly car crashes
here as we start 2021 here in the middle
of april or so
your lieutenants told us he was worried
about a spike as things started to open
up
even more is that something that the
department is focused on
as more businesses open up restaurants
bars etc
so there's three e's in traffic control
education enforcement and engineering
and that's how we address
the traffic problem the engineering
piece is obviously
road construction lights stop signs
everything that goes along with
traffic flow education is for you to be
aware of
those situations in the engineering
space and then
enforcement was us police department
writing tickets
doing car stops and trying to have an
effect on people's behavior
because everybody's affected by that
it's very rare that you're affected by a
violent crime but traffic is a daily
encounter for you and it's very
important for us to keep our
pulse on that and that we pay attention
to it on a daily basis
staying safe on the roads sheriff
lombardo thank you again for joining us
this morning we as always appreciate it
if you have a question for
sheriff joe lombardo you can submit it
over at eight newsnow dot com find out
if it's answered every wednesday